oui alors il y avait bien nick aussi
excédé alors forcément on va revenir sur
la grande première de vienne où il a
fait parler de lui ce week-end car il
s'est pas mal démarquer des autres
coachs on retient surtout sa franchise
ces positions sont deux fauteuils etc
qui clashe avec amel bent regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya m
non parce que vous êtes là je vous jure
c'est parce que c'est parce que c'est
ouf
[Applaudissements]
au mas que c'est un masque noir maxima
mais non
moi j'ai des préservatifs pour les mecs
de préservatifs en peau de crocodile
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop chirurgicale trop beau trop
propre comme ce que tu proposes ça peut
rapidement être riche et sans saveur
quoi alors qu'il ya tout pour faire
quelque chose de très goûtu c'est le
moment où je vis c'est le moment choisi
au timon et pumbaa l'arrivée de yannick
était très bon the voice un énorme
succès est ce que c'est mérité
oui ou non vous allez nous lire dans un
instant et ce qui a fait énormément
parler aussi dangereuse et les
prestations et je vous dire ce qui a
fait le plus parler dans ce volet dans
un sens vous allez voir c'est assez
étonnant
ce ne sont pas les chanteurs vous verrez
ce qui a fait le plus parler la
candidate qui a fait le plus réagir
samedi c'est monteith à elle à 21 ans
elle a décidé de participer à l'aventuré
avec son ami youssef
on va en parler dans un instant mais
juste sur vianney est ce que vous avez
été qui jettent et nicolas pernikoff
vous avez été séduit 1 vous avez moi
j'ai trouvé vianney exceptionnel
incroyable vraiment j'ai découvert un
mec que je connaissais pas c'est un
poids plutôt timide et réservé et là
j'ai trouvé que d'abord il y avait les
bons arguments et la mener un vrai truc
au programme parce que c'est quand même
un programme qui tient sur le jury donc
le retour de pagny a banni il fait
partie des fondamentaux celtitude du
programme c'est le taulier c'est
réaction me viennent et vianney il a
amené ce petit truc que hamel n'a pas
encore et qui a vraiment amené un truc
au programme cette année je trouve que
c'est que quand on re découvre on re
découvre the voice guillaume viany fait
beaucoup de bien il est calme il est
drôle il est juste dans ses habits puis
surtout il est légitime ça fait du bien
d'avoir un vrai artiste estonien aux
autres auteurs puis et puis qui cartonne
en ce moment qui est numéro 1 des charts
les autres ils ont des très grandes
carrières millions à des charts
oui c'est vrai
voilà en plus ça a cartonné en audience
a très bien marché ils ont fait là mais
renonce depuis 2018 c'est ça et vianney
très sympa parce que the voice l'espagne
il faudra montage un peu la netflix avec
des images en coulisses il est très
sympathique dans le programme est génial
c'est une très bonne je les adore alors
on va dernière dernière chose survienne
et c'est vrai c'est une bouffée d'air
frais mais là où je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec nicolas outre le fait
qu'il est brillant incisif super à
l'aise et il apporte beaucoup de choses
moi je trouve qu'il fait beaucoup de
bien aussi aux autres ces derniers je
trouve que j'ai dit oui les mesures il
tire il tire le joli vers le drame en
amont qui me tirait dans le temps à la
prestation de monty ça
là maintenant je voulais dire regardez
elle a repris news ne lui a dit pas qui
veut dire
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
je vais aller pour viviane et voilà
vianney alors bien des caves et il a la
cote 1 tout le monde voulait la tag
année oui gilles verdez ce qu'ils sont
capables
j'ai pas du tout aimé l'émission et
surtout ce casting c'est un casting de
télé-réalité et moi excusez moi cette
jeune femme qui est venue avec son
meilleur ami de belgique c'était une
professionnelle des télé crochets elle a
fait la version néerlandaise
on découvre pas des talents on recycle
les lieux une heure devant un programme
où les champs où les gens chantent comme
des casseroles à huy en vivent aussi un
peu de finir le programme connaît on
devrait découvrir la meilleure voie là
on reprend ailleurs mais ce ne sera pas
vous mais la meilleure chemise et un
truc qui est incroyable c'est le niveau
bien sûr c'est le new paraît que
conseiller m'a fait du bien un peu du
niveau des candidats mais pourquoi il
irait professionnel c'est francky sont
bons thiery latt encore l'école de
musique c'est pas une professionnelle
arrête de dire non est écrit dans mes
oreilles alors les chéris cette année ça
regarde très caustique et arié c'est que
nikos on l'entend de moins en moins mais
moins en moins présents ici aujourd'hui
nikos était complètement absent j'ai
même chronométrer le temps de parole de
nikos sur ce premier prime versus le
prime de l'année dernière il avait plein
fouet par les ou ferment regarder il a
parlé 13 minutes
cette année lors du lancement l'année
dernière et par les 26 minutes ouais ça
fait un peu cher le prime pour tf1 quand
on sait qu'il est payé 1500 m et en
investissement on avait des chiens
essayé d'arrêter pour voilà on sait que
c'est nico son bail à changer non mais
il y en avoir une petite compil de nikos
alors la compil de nikos en fait c'est
tout ce qu'il a fait toute la soirée
c'est vrai que c'est franchement c'est
le plus beau métier du paf qui fait 6
millions 3 donc c'est magnifique
regarder je pense que tu es la maison
refaite et résidentes sont là elle
attend chante pour elle après c'est moi
elle est passée elle a voulu faire un
petit café j'ai promis j'espère qu'ils
vont se retourner parce que prennent
café je le prends dans la tête chose
promise chose due josy je me suis
désinfecter les mains non cafesoca jeter
bas c'est moi qui te fais ton café tu
vois qu'il ya un sucre une petite taille
est tout et je n'ai perdu on va
retrouver une autre saison outils
broquet moi tu fais d'habitude mais tu
oublies tu dors j'ai c'est lui qui
présente la deuxième partie de soirée
donc et rentable il leur entame alors
une soirée qui présente la deuxième
oui bravo isla place de décaler bonnes
infos bonne info alors c'est vrai que ça
a cartonné the void il ya eu le truc a
fait le plus parler c'est le blouson de
nico c'est le blues ont tout le monde en
a parlé sur les renault en russie
il s'est retrouvé en top tweets on en
agneau qui est donc vert kaki en blouson
zippé type appliquer un qu'on le dit pas
un petit pont tour comme ça où tout est
un k way ils vont 3250 euros quand même
vous avez vous avez voulu l'acheter vous
j'ai l'impression oui j'aime bien
et bah écoutez va falloir fabricant
kermesse quoi c'est le même c'est le
même fabricant kermesse à vous aussi
vous avez des infos et la peau sur la
télé mais sur les besoins et vous parlez
pas les chaussures qu'on a derrière qui
oui ah oui monsieur
à oui assez mais les gags à legata si
vous arrivez jaloux non mais c'est vrai
que c'est bon c'est quoi ces du crochet
que la rude concurrence avec les
chaussures il faut les mettre un ouais
il est beau il est intelligent il est
bien gaulée il y avait du bruit dans son
sens courant c'était mieux son il y
avait moins nikos et j'ai trouvé que
c'était mieux c'est de ça on a des gens
et ce alors vous allez dire que ce que j
ai à [ __ ] benjamin castaldi devrait
s'élever n'était pas sage dorothée la
télé et il a fait une révélation sur le
salaire de nikos et des coachs de the
voice il avait déjà dit ici mais c'est
vrai que ça a été repris dans on refait
la télé sur rtl la deuxième radio
c'est pourquoi j'ai signé avec tf1 génie
très bien ma vie entre 2009 et 2010 au
même tarif aujourd'hui c'est de voice le
jury qui fait qu'il fait dans prague
lille prend six cent mille euros négocié
prend 27 1500 euros par problème il fait
danser dans le calcul pareil a ajouté
quand on sait qu'un prime c'est entre 20
être un miroir taxerait polichinelle
[Rires]
c'est non moi j'adore ma chance qu'il
est très cash ils donnent tous les
chiffres et c'est un des rares un des
seuls à avoir une vraie franchise sur
les billets magnétique donc ils avaient
des chiffres différents paddy 550000
euros marc lavoine 400000 euros amel
bent 388 et vianney 340000 les sources
ces publics
c est dernier du journal public oui
stéphane tapis ouais mais aussi j'aime
beaucoup benjamin il a raison de donner
des chiffres mais il donne des chiffres
pour justifier son salaire à lui il
touché à l'épaule de tf1 oui donc je
trouve ça un peu un peu me l'a annoncée
pour expliquer qu'un prénom il y donne
sa fourchette entre 600 et 900 c'est une
grosse fourche est déjà et après il dit
par contre 27 1500 euros pour les causes
justifie pas ton salaire en balançant
s'est décrit des plus franc du paf est
temps que les gens que vous aimez bien
salaire de nikos est énorme ces monstres
27000 euros
c'est la grille tarifaire dont la minute
franchement il sert à rien il parle 13
minutes maximum sinon il ne sert à rien
défaut cyril qu'on l'enlève delahaye
convoi de baisser ils ont baissé les
salaires vous savez que wind pas d'y
toucher 800 mille euros et mika touché
quand même un million de millions d'ha
tant qu ils ont nettement baissé
et sachez que les candidats gagnent par
semaine 500 euros ce qui est le minimum
syndical d'accord être obligé de leur
donner 500 longue durée
le meilleur alors une autre tu rigoles
at il un candidat qui a fait beaucoup
parler de lui samedi c'est benjamin il a
chanté rêver de mylène farmer mais elle
a fait beaucoup fait réagir c'est savoir
garder
[Musique]
il est
oh la la
ah ouais bon soir comment vous
appelez-vous benjamin mais vous parlez
comme ou chanter et donc au téléphone on
vous dit bonjour bonjour mesdames
après je dis non c'est mademoiselle oui
moi je suis pas daccord origines chauve
que le casting a été super bien c'est
avec des candidats comme ça que le
concept 2 aures prend tout son sens
c'est quand y'a une décorrélation entre
la voix et le physique donc c'est super
ça a été j'ai alors on va voir ce qu'on
pense aux téléspectateurs les chérit le
casting était l'auteur oui 60 il réussit
par non à 38% ça va cartonner
vraiment bravo parce que ça a été très
très très très fort